Trevor Wallace is one of the funniest
people on the internet he's known for
his parodies of people who own airpods
drink white claw and who are named Kyle
among many others today we get to sit
down and talk about the business behind
some of the most viral sketches on the
internet where he finds his inspiration
and how you're able to do practically
anything that you want on today's
episode of smash the like button sure
but first we gotta thank our sponsor
streamyard people always say they want
to start making content but for most
it's hard to get the ball rolling and
when you've never made a video before it
could be very difficult to know where to
start I've seen firsthand that
post-production could be one of the most
daunting tasks for new creators that's
why I recommend for anyone thinking
about getting into content creation that
you start by using streamer stream yard
is a live streaming Studio platform
that's perfect for people looking to get
into content creation with streamer you
can create high quality content right
from your browser and you can stream
directly to Facebook YouTube LinkedIn
and several other platforms they even
make it simple to brand and customize
your videos before you even go live you
could even multi-stream to all of your
social media platforms at once to be
able to maximize your content's Outreach
whether you just want to start live
streaming or easily record new content
stream yard makes it simple to get
professional and Polished content every
single time so get started for free
today using our link down below and you
can start making high quality content
quickly and easy like I said for free
with streamyard again the link is down
below in the description to get started
today and now let's get to the podcast
Trevor thank you so much for meeting us
in Vegas in a karaoke room in a karaoke
room spots in here you think so I think
plenty copious amounts yeah dog yeah
karaoke in Vegas well that explains it
uh I think we gotta start because Jack
is a funny story oh yeah yeah I didn't
think we'd start off with this okay but
uh twice me today I did I introduced it
was horribly embarrassing but I did
introduce myself twice later on so thank
you I literally just got this my grandma
got it so I appreciate that yeah
Grandma's love sweaters they do love
sweaters did she make that herself she
did not make this herself
you got a funny story yeah yeah the
funny story so you actually performed at
UCSB I think this was like two and a
half years ago probably and I remember I
showed up the line was way too long it
was a free show I knew I would not make
it in so I was like circumnavigating my
way throughout the throughout the line
trying to figure out if I can make it in
I definitely couldn't I went around the
venue and while I was walking around the
venue to try to find a place to sneak in
I found a door with a crack in it yeah
and I looked through this Christmas on
me and I saw you I remember this I
remember I saw you no I remember the
crack on the door and I remember people
like because what it was is like there's
this comedy club with this at
I do a Santa Barbara called laughology
students put it on yeah and I was and I
would do it when I had like no nothing I
would just do like 10 minute sets and
there'd be a headliner I would just do
it just to do it because I was early in
the stand-up career and then they booked
me for this and then it's like the stuff
started taking off for me and then I was
like like you guys want me to do this
and they're like let's do two shows
they're like no let's just stick with
one and then the word got out and like
my demo is frat yeah my demo is college
My Demo is UCSB is like that's Isla
Vista that's my those are my people
right right so it sold in seconds yeah
not so it's free right I got paid like
20 bucks but that was it I don't know at
that point I'm just doing comedy to just
stay sharp and just do it like you know
just work out longer sets and um I
forget how much it was it wasn't a lot
but it's uh it's a really fun uh all Los
Angeles comedians I've probably done
like laughology it's a really fun show
so I remember I was in the back pacing
just going over my head and then there's
like cracks and there's like Windows and
then this guy shows up so what happens
yeah yeah it wasn't weird right but I
just I was like yo Trevor Traverse
Trevor and I was trying to get your
attention you looked at me smiling I
think you like got up and walked away
and then I continued walking around the
venue found a place in the back couldn't
make it in oh really I wait no I could
not make it in the line was huge dude
like there were so many people that
couldn't make it you had a lot of fans
there I think a lot of people it was in
a um like a uh lecture hall yeah and I
think a lot of people didn't know how
big the lecture hall was it wasn't very
big it maybe held like 200 or 300 so
there's like 600 people in line right
mathematically that doesn't make sense
right unless you're sitting on laps but
right lucky for you guys I have a show
at the Mirage tomorrow so come on there
we go
all right cool it's cool thank you man
yeah the Santa Barbara was great but
then you met you made it yeah I met you
afterwards right so there was like you
were doing a meet and greet you're ever
so gracious yeah you were saying hello
to everybody you came outside shook the
hands of the fans took some photos and I
went up to him like hey man I was that
guy that like that whisper deal and
you're like yeah it was a little weird
but uh cool and then we took the fun
I I was looking for it this morning and
I think it was on my other phone which I
transferred my laptop I'll send it to
you okay I got the photo you know what
we'll put it up on screen I'll put it up
like you're reacting
would I remember you like with the
outfit or whatever yeah yeah but yeah
there's people up front so I've met you
three times wow not just two yeah three
yeah today yeah how did you get started
and all that I got started I've always
just loved comedy like it's wild to say
but my mom found like something in like
third or fourth grade it was like what's
your dream job and like with the
spelling like DoodleBob spelling like I
wrote comedian I spelled it wrong I
think I spelled it with a K it's funny
she's pretty on brand yeah but I like
always just love comedy I grew up on
like Jim Carrey and Robin Williams and I
just like that's all I cared about I
never All My Friends Are Juicy
Braveheart you see [ __ ] Titanic and
I'm like no it's not funny it's sad yeah
you know so I always was in to that and
then when I was 17 my mom it's a very
Disney Channel story my mom cut out
something from the paper and it said
stand-up comedy Workshop classes this
was in Ventura which is
where that is I grew up there really
yeah 805 Boy Yes 805 805 boy yeah came
around that's what I thought I thought I
knew that yeah yeah because people would
talk about you in Ventura yeah big deal
in Camarillo it's me and somebody that
was on Big Bang Theory and uh two
baseball players delmy young Ventura
comedy Workshop classes
and then my mom coming on the paper and
then anything your mom tells you to do
at that age you're like I'm gonna do
this [ __ ] how am I gonna do that and
then eventually some time went by and I
was like you know what maybe I should
check this out and I show up to this
comedy club on a Saturday and it's like
me and like six other people trying to
get into comedy and there's a guy that's
got Randy lubis he owned the comedy club
but he's teaching it and there was like
assignments he'd be like all right
here's a newspaper write some jokes on
it and then I was writing some he's like
it's pretty good but I kind of only been
doing this like today
and like I've never done this and then
he just kind of like oh you kind of have
like a knack for it then he helped me
build like a five minute set and then
from there I did that set on like the
Showcase which was essentially like a
dance recital it was like all of our
friends and family from me and the other
comedians there and like I just had this
Rush of energy like I was like I never
played Sports really growing up or I did
but I wasn't good at it I think I shot
at my own goal twice in soccer
you know friendly fire was on that game
right right but that was the first time
I felt like I had like a game-winning
catch or like a home run like it felt
like this like this rush and it felt
right so I did that and then I started
doing stand-up and then when I went to
college Vine came out and then my buddy
Jorge shout out Jorge great guy just got
married
this is your wedding gift to me
um and he's like dude you got to make
Vine you got to make one in the chat
this is where funny people are and I was
like I don't believe it I start
scrolling nice sure enough I started
seeing funny people and I think I was
just like all right and I lived in a
fried house so it's super easy what year
was this by the way
uh 2013 okay sure yeah and I think I
just feel like I was making videos and
then like other guys in the frat house
would see me like make a behind but dude
I want to be in one so I had just like a
disposal of just like roaming just a
revolving door of frat guys we like Kyle
One Cop one
and then I had one kind of hit and it
didn't do anything for me but I got
recognized going to class one day and I
was like
I just made it San Jose State Legend
um but like I was happy that vine never
got really big for me because it just
showed me how a video can work you have
an idea you post it
bombs you have an idea Post-it bombs oh
but this one gets a little bit of
traction gets the share you see how the
internet works yeah that Snowball Effect
so at that point I was a sophomore and I
was doing Vines all sophomore year
junior year and then towards the end of
Junior years when I got really back into
stand up and I was doing like open mics
after class and
um senior year moved out of the frat
house and I was like doing a good amount
of both mics and then just moved
straight to LA right after and just yeah
were you getting paid for doing stand-up
shows or were you just doing it for
experience no you just yeah you there's
really not a lot of money in stand up in
the very early days at all you should
pay like seven dollars or like a chicken
finger and like I literally inventor one
time got paid with a bread bowl clam
chop no way yeah right next door there's
a place what was it called there's a
place with clam chowder essentially
right next to the Ventura Harbor comedy
club back then and the guy's like I'll
get you a bullet chowder and I was like
[ __ ] and what was it like your first
time going up on stage I like blackout I
remember like the first laugh and I
always try to laugh as quick as possible
on stage because that like sets the
anxiety and like that anxiousness it
just kind of locks you in sure so the
first time I got a laugh I was like
shocked on stage like I said I forgot it
was a quick joke yeah and I get this
like little laugh and I was like oh [ __ ]
and then like I just picked my head up
and the five minutes flew by so how does
it work do you have a whole set that's
just memorized or do you kind of wing it
do you ever wing it yeah yeah I mean I
would say in my head there's like
picture like a Spotify playlist and
there's
you know 40 songs and I stick to these
but sometimes I'm like let me pull from
here and pull from here but in the back
there's like a skeleton of like
starting to Middle to finishing jokes
and then kind of like I can like if
somebody in the audience yells something
out about
whatever the horse is and I go oh dude I
have a horse bit from three years ago
now I can you know you make it seem
seamless somebody's like horses and then
you do your bit on it people like this
guy's [ __ ] Shin lamb over here that's
smart yeah so it's just all keeping it
in your head but I mean I essentially
have like what I normally start ish with
is like this chunk and then I end with
this chunk
um but I think the on the Fly stuff is
the most fun yeah and what kept you
motivated to post on vine when you
probably weren't making any money from
it and uh it was probably a grind it's
just addicting I think it's just fun I
just like I mean it's literally like the
same reason you walk up to the casino
dudes are just on the slots you put each
poll is a video and you go What's it
gonna be done What's it gonna be oh this
one kind of hit we got one of the we got
one of the slot machines to light up you
know it's like when when you don't get
jackpot but you get one of the big ones
you're like oh close so funny you
described it like that that's exactly
how it is for me with posting videos
it's like you see how it ranks one out
of ten got a one today
like gotta do it again that's what the
difference between stand up and uh and
videos is for me uh feeling wise is
stand up is instant you say something
either crowd's like we [ __ ] with it it's
not like somebody's like they get
together and they come back and they're
like that's a seven out of 10. so stand
up instant yeah you feel it it's
reciprocated there's no faking that but
videos it's like you post something then
the algorithm is like is this go against
guidelines is this good is this bad yeah
um uh sometimes [ __ ] pops immediately
but now like I have a video that I'll
like kind of like do okay and then I'll
like pick my head up and a couple days
later like kicked up in the back end or
it flopped in the beginning or I hit
right off the bat like there's too many
there's too much waiting for videos to
to really feel the response from the
audience it's interesting it's comments
I always are good though you know if you
want your mental health yeah read
comments okay no I absolutely stopped
reading comments I am done reading
comments yes for any YouTubers watching
I read the comments good what do they
say about what is a because podcast fans
are the best fans in the world what do
they say they can be touchy about some
of the guests that we've had on in the
past have you had problematic people no
it's just maybe people that uh like
we've definitely we have had problematic
people on the podcast I would say but
the thing is just because someone's
problematic I don't think like there's
any reason to just like not let them
speak you know what I mean like
to a certain extent but I still think
that it's good to challenge your
opinions on everything yeah that's why I
mean the edgy guests get the most
Traction in the most views we've had
some of the clips get like five 10
million views and people are like I hate
this one commenting because yeah they
agree or disagree but if somebody's just
a wholesome guy you know if you have
Neil Patrick Harris on here everyone's
like I love this guy you know that's all
the comments but if you're somebody
who's edgy you're gonna get the people
that are like I love this guy and
they'll be like why the [ __ ] would you
have this person yeah so you get both
sides but I'm curious for you uh because
you mentioned YouTube in the videos how
do you balance what you want to make
with the YouTube's algorithm and pushing
the content that might be you know
little on the line I essentially just
make stuff I want to make and if it gets
demonetized
in my head all views lead to something
greater so if the video gets demonetized
all right
somebody who's a fan of that video might
now want to do a brand deal you know I I
try not to let the
the little green dollar sign next to
your video or the the yellow like
demonetizer like limited monetization
get too much in my head because I have
such a catalog of videos over the past
five years if not more that it's like if
one video gets flagged then you go but
what if it's not just getting flagged
but what if it's not getting recommended
because now it seems like that's that's
a big thing where YouTube is just
deciding not to push certain videos yeah
and so you have to tailor that if you
want to reach the audience I is I mean
it's unfortunate because you put a lot
of work into it and you never really
know until you hit
post and publish how it's going to do
sometimes it's unfortunate you're just
like damn all right but I'm always like
what's next you know that and that's
what what I like about stand up and
videos is like if a joke bombs you go
okay I'm not gonna sit in this moment
and be like damn I'm not gonna just you
just be like what's next how do I keep
going from here what's the next Joey
after so if a video doesn't do well if
it's not getting pushed so you go all
right whatever maybe we'll get picked up
in three months keep going yeah but also
I just you know if the video is five
minutes you have a couple clips for tick
tock you can post from that so I'm like
something will hit sure what was it like
for you moving to LA
how are you supporting yourself back
then uh just through comedy so I had a
day job I lived in a pool house in
Studio City a Studio City uh yeah it was
a pool house it literally my
my best friend's older brother's friend
let's see if I got the right best friend
older brother and then he has a friend's
friend yeah all right was living at this
house and then one of his roommates was
recording just guitar stuff in the back
in the pool house and just random was
like um
I think I went to go and just go out
with them one night and they're like hey
dude you could rent that for like 350
bucks if you want and I was like sold
because my other two friends that I was
gonna move in with were like we're down
but we won't be there for like eight to
nine months so I was like let me just
get out there already slept on an air
mattress but it had a inflatable
headboard there you go nice yeah we
almost brought a lady back and crickets
as uh literally would come over at night
literally there's a gap this big in the
door crickets will just come in you
didn't close that off like put a towel
on there no I like it was like the free
comment right right some homies yeah so
what was the question how did I get here
how's the sporting myself yeah so I was
doing that but I was also working two
internships one of the Groundlings was
just an improv theater a lot of uh big
actors and stuff have come out of that
and then I was also working at aldev
digital if you know them they're not a
big YouTube channel they're not as big
anymore but they did a bunch of I was
all comedy music it was ran by uh
Russell Simmons so he did like Def Jam
comedy back in the day this was his
version it was all deaf digital
um so they were putting me in videos too
it was like comedy stuff and it was some
like unscripted stuff just like kind of
debates and stuff like that and also
sketches so I was doing that I was doing
the two internships all that digital
eventually brought me on full time uh
then I was a paid intern and then I was
salary stopped working at Groundlings
and then I was just work I think I was
making 40K a year at all deaf digital
and I was pumped because my rent was
350. so I had like some money
um and then I was just doing open mics
every night and Vine had died at this
point I wasn't really making too many
videos it's like 2015 and then Facebook
I was like Facebook's gonna be big for
videos Facebook and YouTube so I started
making videos again like 2016 2017
that's when I had this one character
about Zumiez the skate shop kind of hit
and that hit on Facebook and YouTube all
right there's that same feeling I have
when vine hit I was like time to double
down all right here we go I'm feeling
the momentum again things just took off
like or was it more gradual but it's I
always think about my career as like a
fire and it's like you want to keep
throwing logs on the fire sure so each
video is a log and I was like okay I
have a little spark here with the
zoomy's character let's just keep you
know keep throwing wood at it let's keep
growing this so I did like put like
seven or eight videos as it's like
zoomy's character but then I didn't want
to be pigeonholed I don't want to be
like kind of like cornered as that so
then I um
started doing a little bit different
ones but I'll do a few and if those in
here then I'd go back to the Zoomies one
is like a Fail-Safe
but at that point like it was a slow
growth and then December 2018 I think it
was right when the airpods got big I
remember that day yeah
it blew up yeah it was on like right at
front page and then world star reposted
it and I was like I was at a coffee shop
in Camarillo when I saw a world sorry
posing I just kept refreshing my
Instagram and each time it'd be like a
couple more hundred a couple more
hundred followers and that that video
gave me like I went from like 60k to
like 85k on Instagram and at the point I
mean I can't I'm in Cambria at a coffee
shop I'm like somebody give me a latte
it wasn't a world song but uh Camarillo
California isn't the demographic for
Worldstar to imagine so but it is for
airpods it is for airpods yes I could
come up with that idea it's just like
everybody was kind of like I was just
tired of my friends just being like you
know it's just walk us through the the
bit a little bit Yeah if anyone's
viewing does now
airpods were really the first
kind of like Bluetooth headset or
headphones that like really it wasn't
even about the quality it was just the
look it was the short white stub that
was like as a fashion statement yeah you
know people were just wearing it and not
even on the phone not even listening to
music it just it was earrings
every freaking Tech guy had those and
like it that with a vape and a Patagonia
vest couldn't tell me nothing
on a bird scooter with airpods in oh my
God Unstoppable yeah yeah so I think I
started to just hear people talking
about it there's a few like memes here
and there and then I was like dude I can
make a character out of this and then I
just did that and then I just pictured
like what would this bag it's in every
character is just in a situation for me
all right you know people see me like
this Craig you're right I'm not hiding I
was in a frat I've had the same haircut
since I was like nine like very much I
understand what I am so I just
accentuate that and then I go what is me
out of 10. if a three level dude is me
just vibing posted up with the air
mattress how do I accentuate this so I
had like I had like a jean jacket with
like a turtleneck on and you know I'm
just right I was in Santa Monica when I
filmed that video I had airpods in just
riding around I just was like how do I
just keep going with that and then that
did well so that um
like a parody after that and that was
great is they kept dropping airpods
a year later they did airpods the pros
so I go all right same guy we're doing
Pros the year goes by airpod Max come
out guess what's going on and look uh
it's it's fun because it's you know
people almost like look to me I would
get tweets and people would be like the
pros came out today are you excited for
the video and that's the best thing is
like when people think of you
before the video's even out yeah like
this drop and when are you dropping so
it was fun uh and I did it for all the
airpods and you know in 2024 when they
dropped the new ones that are exact same
but have a different shape like octagons
yeah I'll make another video do you
remember how much you made off the first
video like I'd imagine like Facebook
would pay pretty well on something like
that I wish I do
um I I
I remember my first Facebook check yeah
I was like this isn't real I didn't
believe it and then I looked I feel like
this is a clip coming I know how this
works this is the class subtitles right
here I remember the first Facebook check
I ever got was for thirty thousand
dollars and I was like I was driving
and I had the biggest smile on my face I
was like there's no way there's no way
that this like all these videos equal to
this like it like I thought it was gonna
be like
like a like a Facebook was gonna be like
roughly 30k and then you get it and it's
like fourteen dollars like what they're
like taxes
but I was like mind blown I was like how
is this
and I remember the song paid in full
came on it's by this guy's safe and
cardi I think it's safe
and I was just blasting this up just
because it was so it felt the theme like
it literally came on when I checked my
account paid in full and that was
and that was like when things were on on
my Facebook does not make that nap but
this is when things are on on and I was
just
static so when you quit your job I quit
my job in 2018
I worked at all Dev digital for like
three years three and a half years sure
and I remember I like asked my parents I
didn't really ask what I told him I was
like I'm um quit my job to do comedy and
I was like very nervous to do that
because I had mentioned it before and
they were always like yeah for sure
but definitely they have health
insurance stay there Kaiser gold
Platinum good stuff uh and then I
when I told my 2018 they were like yeah
we knew this was coming and then after
that I was just like let's you know and
what was the Catalyst to you quitting I
had a friend Kev on stage my mentor he's
the guy that worked at all death digital
one of my favorite comedians funniest
guy he was um he was about to leave and
I was like Kev I want to leave too how
much money should I have in the bank
before I leave you know people say that
you should have like three months salary
this or that and then I told her how
much I had in the bank and he's like and
you're still here like leave you're fine
you'll be all right and I remember that
moment after I was like yeah this guy
has a wife and two kids and if he's
telling me that that's enough money for
a single guy living in Santa Monica
[Music]
it wasn't even an insane amount for what
will you guys guess how much you think
I'm gonna guess a single guy yeah I was
gonna say like 60 60 yeah 60k 60k in my
bank account that's planning that was uh
when that was after months and some
months of YouTube and Facebook and also
just saving up money from all that
digital I didn't spend money I I when I
moved out of the pool house with my
friends and I lived with two of them and
one guy paid 900 one guy paid a thousand
I paid 800 for my room
and I that's I was my only coach I had
that and I paid off my car I had a
Mazda3 Flex nice hit off my car and I
paid 800
um so but everything I did was either
YouTube or stand up so I was working and
then doing YouTube and stand up so all
three of those were generating not a lot
from stand up and some from YouTube but
when I saw like checks coming in from
YouTube I was like this is the same
amount I'm getting for two weeks pad all
left digital like I think I'm good
uh I left and then this I think I was
starting a tour with some and then it
was the summer of 2019 where like three
videos back to back to back just all
like hit and then I was like let's which
videos are this it was the Kyle video uh
this is making fun of dudes named Kyle I
like that one the hometown bro video and
then of course the infamous White Club
video all three of those were like me
and my friend Chad Charlie's if you know
him yeah best guy it was like this era
when I bleached my hair and like every
video was hitting so whenever she's
bombing on YouTube I'll like text Chad
and like [ __ ] going blonde that's funny
it's it's like it just felt like but
that summer is like dude you got to do
frosted tips yeah I feel like that
really like
it really would yeah I'd be down frosted
tips go hard like the guy stuck in the
90s I think would do so well yeah Lance
Bass yeah
thrift store I think I think that's a
banger for you oh then yeah guys stuck
in the night he's got the jinko jeans
yeah it's crazy how much those three
YouTube videos must have blown you up
though because when you did like I said
when when I came to the UCSB thing I did
not expect it to be as big as it was
there were hundreds of hundreds of
people there
it was crazy yeah but what it is and I
tell this to every YouTuber it's like
the the fact that and this goes for the
same thing for music it's like I had a
bad catalog I've been making videos
since like 2017. so we got two years on
me of making videos and I was doing a
video every Monday right so there's two
years so when these videos start popping
they can now
watch these videos but then also
backtrack and they listen and they watch
and they just binge and that's how you
lock in a fan because if I had no other
videos people watch one video they go
that's it there's nowhere to go right
but the more it's like when you find an
artist yep you you find one song There's
and you listen to a album then another
album all of a sudden you're three Steve
Lacy happens deep you know you [ __ ]
love this guy but if you just had one
song you'd be like that's cool but
when's his next project and then there's
a lot of pressure on that next project
because it's you know it but if if I
have 50 videos behind me you can click
through 50 of them I'm sure you might
like 12 of them but those 12 you'll love
but
think it's just it I so so keep creating
and you don't want your first to hit
build that catalog build that Library so
when [ __ ] does hit people have [ __ ] to
pick and choose from I'm curious what's
your creative process like how do you
come up with these ideas I think it's
being observant of what's going on
around you the trends are all around you
it's just really you know the Wyclef
thing came to me because I used my buddy
Jason I was like he was he where he got
fired from Deloitte for drinking too
much like he's like my demo Deloitte
Finance whatever the [ __ ] he was doing
over there I don't really know but he's
like he was a guy who told me about like
pickleball he was the guy who was like
nutted for that crazy zoom in on that
yeah he was like he was the guy who's
first started drinking white clothes in
the Santa Monica apartment I remember he
was the way he was describing it so he's
like dude these are [ __ ] they're like
epic like you feel like drunk but you
feel skinny you feel like lighter and
like he he was Santa Barbara was he on
fire stick I think huh yeah but well
interesting response I wasn't it I
wasn't in France
GDI for that that's what the frag guys
would call you I forgot to stand for
anyways but he was like he was my
barometer he was the dude he had a Hydro
Flask he's the reason I made a Hydro
Flask video he was like my like perfect
bro right down the center of America you
know because he because he he felt just
like he felt like what the uh a mixture
of just all the people in Los Angeles
but also kind of just like Central
America like he just felt
like like he was a guy I could base
anything off of so he always had a Hydro
Flask boom make a video off that he
always was drinking the white clothes
and I was like all right let me try one
of these and then I start getting more
into it and nobody had made a white Club
video and that was like it felt like I
think a trend is like uh catching a wave
I don't surf but I would imagine this
would be like it's like it's it's
building up and if you get in at the
right time you ride the out of it but so
many people jump on when it's already
breaking there's a lot of people
paddling paddling paddling the same
thing I made a video on Tiger King and I
was a I was one of I'm not to sound like
[ __ ] uh Soulja Boy over here saying I
did it first but I was very early in the
Tiger King parodies and then that hit
and then people pushed out like two or
three weeks after the series was big and
it you know it's all about just getting
in right before it breaks you know yeah
and what's your team well that was your
creative process yeah so just watching
this guy
and he's starting a brand and I swear
this is not a lie uh he's starting a
brand about uh
uh what's it called when they when they
shift stuff to you on a regular basis
Drop Shipping oh no but
um subscription type subscription
business decision based uh jerk off
lotion I swear I swear on my life he
swear all my life I swear on my life
he's so funny man he he'll like text me
and be like I got an investor meeting
coming up this guy was on Shark Tank and
I'm like this is all for Lube he's in
like he'll send me like the photo of
like the product and The Branding he's
like what do you think about this what
do you think about that so he's making
jerk off lotion in Austin Texas he's
doing well
I think so huh you know he's definitely
moisturized I can tell you that much
yeah but um this guy is your ticket man
yo yeah he's you he's great yeah um I
love him I was one of his um Grims when
I was wedding but um so he was like the
gold mine but I'm like where so his name
is Jason I go where do I find the jasons
in the world you know
um when does this come out by the way uh
it could be this Sunday okay cool yeah
well I have this video coming out and
it's just about like guys like dangly
cross earrings right it's just one of
those things you look up at a club funny
I see them everywhere now he's still
able to pick these things out of
reaction is exactly what I want in the
video if somebody noticed it everywhere
but I've never like put YouTube but you
never bring it out correct that's the
reaction I want on all the videos it's
like dude people do do that oh I mean uh
Tesla they all all these and I have one
I'm an idiot
but every Tesla owner for the most part
I'd say
an 80 I have a custom license plate and
I've been sitting on that idea for so
long they're all Customs like lol guys
dude I gotta show you my license plate
what do you have what car do you have by
the way how much money do you have uh
yes well what like 3.2 mil liquid or
what
No Man's net worth the fact that you
said liquid alone you have millions
racked up the strobe lights are going
off over there
so here's the license plate
God wait this is a test yeah it's the
Roadster the Roadster
2010 came out with that
2010 dude I would take a photo of your
life and be like this guy has like Elon
I'm about to bust you know oh my God but
I essentially made a video just because
I kept seeing him everywhere and I
worked it into a stand-up bit then I go
this is funny but like the visual of
this is that's how I decided if it goes
stand up or video I go is this more
visual is this more of a story in the
visual aspect and then now people tag me
and be like no gas here gas LOL and it's
just like and now I see him everywhere
and that and that people attack him in
me
that was in a sense people will tag me
in it and be like yo I [ __ ] see this
[ __ ] everywhere so it's like the you're
bringing something that people have seen
but haven't talked about out and they go
yo I have seen that that's incredible
3.2 Miller what are we talking about oh
I need to know what what's the context I
don't know liquid you got it everything
assets or net worth
I don't know what the question is
everything try to if you had to
net worth is net worth net worth there
we go yeah 18 million
[Music]
like that
that's a good point yeah that's a really
good point what's your net worth not
that I don't know I I wish I knew oh you
know you got it now
here's what's [ __ ] up so I'm gonna
clip the part where it leaves yours out
I'm over here
I don't know just that part
um I'm buying a house in like a week so
I'm nervous it it's fine but after I buy
the house it's not gonna be fine how
much is the house the house is uh like
1.7 LA or California L.A okay how much
so how much are you putting down
that's a cardboard box yeah 20 okay
that's about standard and do some math
we could do some math on that yeah run
the numbers backwards so you get a one
and a half million dollar loan on that
no it's about one point 1.3 1.4 your
background is all uh housing right yeah
it's real estate
so seven so do you realize your payments
yes your payment's gonna be probably
around seven six sixty five seven
thousand dollars a month mortgage plus
property tax yeah so that's gonna make
it about eight I just I so I pay so
you're making more than twenty five
thousand dollars oh yeah like without
yeah yeah
I am right technically from the lender's
perspective I'm wearing kids shorts bro
I'm out here look at this cost I don't
know
I'm kidding dude I'm not I don't spend
crazy I'm not like
every anytime I have like I wear
something like jewelry I go this isn't
me I'm not you know like anytime I like
post anything nice it's a character and
I'm like like being like yo guess who
got it like that and then the next thing
is me at a [ __ ] Norms eating steak
and eggs but the steak is like eight
dollars right like everything I post is
like a joke like I like I never share
like personal life stuff I never [ __ ]
what I'm going through I'm always just
like how can I make this water bottle
funny why don't you share like more
personal people don't care I think they
would really listen to my podcast
they're very tapped in they're very in
the now stiff socks 18 mil it's crazy I
think people if they listen to my
podcast they know
full versions of me they know what I'm
going through they I've had my dad on
the podcast they know exactly who I am
where I come from but I just like
I've
when it comes to social media I just
want people to land on my page and be
able to laugh
and the second they land on there and
I'm over there being like my cat mittens
was my everything they're like cool now
I'm sad you know so I just I keep that
stuff and sure instead of posting it and
getting uh likes from people about my
life stuff I just go to therapy and I
[ __ ] crush a therapy you know so I
just I don't know it just feels like
when um
I just feel and this is not a great
stance but it feels like when you go to
like an Instagram models page and you're
like nice ass and then you click the
next one she's like here's what's wrong
with bud and you're like God damn what's
going on here
I get it I just want to see some
pictures yeah you know what does Tulum
look like why is every girl in Tulum
I want to go to Tulum I agree with what
you're saying that's kind of an epiphany
that I had in the past few months is
like like try to be a force for good and
like optimism and happiness just in
general like even if the negative stuff
okay I know I'm saying this right next
to Graham but like even if I could say
some like negative stuff or be mean or
whatever and it would be funny what
negative stuff we say about Graham right
now well I wouldn't say negative stuff
about Graham yeah which is like the
million dollars he knows he knows better
like like being a negative person for
for comedy or whatever or like if I'm
with my friends I feel like even if it's
funny and it gets a laugh or whatever
like at the same time like it's probably
better just to be a force for good and
just try to be an optimistic guy it's
like a wrong way to do it like like I'm
not saying like if I go to some chick's
page expressing your political thoughts
that's not wrong it's her page who am I
to say that she can or can't do any of
that yeah I'm just saying me personally
I don't want to involve any of that plus
also
one thing I think Marshmallow is the
smartest DJ in the world because he has
zero personal identity he's just a a
figure right you don't associate any
thoughts with him that are like
oh that's just a this guy from that
place or he looks like this so he gets
like you just get that it's just a god
like it's not even a god it's just a
character it's a character yeah so when
people go to my page I want people have
the same thoughts they're not like whoa
this guy's leaning left this guy's
leaning right like oh this guy hates
this it's just like you're just smart
it's just one it's just a comedy page
yeah
um and I think that
yeah I don't I I don't know I only post
like random stuff but like I'm not gonna
like I'm always curious do you ever feel
like you have to uphold this character
that you've kind of like presented
yourself as for example coming on this
podcast do you feel like you have to be
funny or if you get recognized by a fan
do you feel like you have to be that
character uh
no I think you just have to be nice
human just personable because I think
like how's that some event last night
here and this girl it's like what do you
do and I was like I do comedy and then
the the best response that every
comedian loves is really tell me a joke
no I was gonna I was gonna say that I
was gonna be like make me laugh I know
but that sounds like very like you're a
king and I'm a Jester and you'll kill me
if you'll laugh like make me laugh
around me boy and I think if you just
give me some time and you talk to me a
little bit you'll find a way to laugh
you'll find something funny but like
make me laugh it's very like knock knock
jokes what do you say to that uh I just
say no or I'll be like dude it's I'm at
a [ __ ] we're at a karaoke bar right
now this is not a good setup for this
right right
um
oh yeah I don't know it's just every
comedian is like the least favorite do
you ever worry about the jokes that
you're saying and maybe it gets you in
hot water because it seems like comedy
in general is moving more towards like a
safer place where you can't make certain
jokes anymore like it seems like the
jokes that were made 20 30 years ago are
just unacceptable now you
you kind of err on the side of like
you know in the same sense of like what
I was saying a little bit ago is like I
don't pick a side where it's like like
you could watch me I think anybody could
watch me and find whether they like it
or not they don't watch me be like yeah
this is funny if you're blank this is
funny if you're blank you know if you're
Republican you'll love him if you're
this or that like I just I'm right down
the middle I don't talk politics I don't
talk anything that would like make
people feel a certain way
um because again my whole goal is for
people just to laugh just take the mind
off of what they're going whether
they're on a five minute break whether
they're on a breakup whatever the [ __ ]
like the amount of messages I get people
like that are deployed in like
Afghanistan or they're going through a
breakup or they lost their dad or
something like hey your comedy helps get
me through that that's all I want I
don't I don't push the envelope in a
sense of like you know tackling crazy
issues or saying wild stuff it's not for
me I just all I want is laugh and the
second you get two
too edgy you know there's people who
will love you there's people who are
very successful at that but that's just
not for me I think I'd rather go broad
audience and uh cast a bigger net that's
fair what's your team like is it just
you do you have an editor I have me a
main editor John best editor I know uh I
used to edit all my stuff until like
2019 John came on and then it's me John
and then another guy Kyle who tours with
me and he films all the stand up and
those are those like the three that kind
of make it work and then I have an
assistant that's yeah really it why'd
you start your podcast I had been
wanting to do one and I was with this
guy Michael blaston who's the other
co-host and we were at an open mic in LA
and
we just hit it off we were just talking
because this was right when I was about
to quit my job I think where I just quit
my job and he was doing a bunch of
college gigs and as a stand-up comedian
in the early days College gigs pay the
best
they're I mean they're like they just
for whatever reason they don't know how
to price comedy they're like here's five
grand and at the time you're like that's
insane so he was like doing con he was
doing colleges and at that point I was
so young and stand up I was like dude
like
you get these college gigs and then I
was starting to pop on YouTube and he
goes he goes well how do you get these
views
we're going back and forth back and
forth he's telling me game on like
stand upside I'm telling the game on
videos and we had like a three hour
conversation at this coffee shop in
Koreatown after this open mic
and the next day he called me he goes do
you want to start a podcast and I was
like yeah and I'd already been thinking
about this perfect storm and then we
just met at a coffee shop in Culver City
and we just pitched ideas back and forth
back and forth for some reason stiff
socks just stuck
who came who came up with that idea I
think
I want to say Michael I think it was I
think we were going back forth back and
forth like like I said like
like sticky socks and he was like what
about stiff sock like it was an alley
thing okay
um but yeah that's always funny about
the names like people will like get
close with it but your sticky socks
right come come Nikes come suck what is
it I'm like I'm with my father right now
my dad's like still socks check out my
episode can we break down the uh the
business of things a little bit like if
you were to have a pie you're gonna make
each piece assign it each a percentage
where's your what's your income look
like on that pie that's a great question
I would probably say
podcast that dude is pretty like I'd say
the big three-hour podcast touring
videos and I would say podcasting and
videos is about the same and I'd say 40
videos no no no I'd say 50 is videos and
brand deals in one category and then uh
25 touring 25 podcast it's pretty good
for the podcast but you guys are doing
well yeah it's awesome man but again
podcast fans are the best they they're
just supportive uh we have a patreon and
you know that's got got some people in
there too and it's just uh
who really enjoy listening to us yeah
that's what I've noticed I think podcast
listeners like they connect with you on
a different level oh dude than just like
watching like a YouTube video or
something like that which is somebody
like come up to me on the street be like
how's the dentist uh today I'm like what
yeah yeah I heard the episode today you
went to the dentist yeah in Culver City
yeah yeah you they thought it was cavity
but it wasn't how was that
I forget that I just project my entire
life right for hours upon hours every
week on Apple and Spotify and everywhere
and then I just forget that people
listen so when people reference that and
even when shows I'll like on a show I'll
be or on a podcast I'm like dude I love
sour skittles next show people like I
brought you sour skittles it's just
that's cool it's the coolest thing ever
I'm always amazed at people that wait at
9am WE Post every Sunday yeah and if we
end up posting like like that's the
right if we posted at 10 A.M there are
people like you know where's the podcast
I'm like I'm waiting for it I feel so
terrible because everybody it's always
Jack's fault I'm ready it's it's Jack
usually that yep
for me sleeping no I it's not rising and
grinding every I've never said this
publicly on the podcast but I have to be
up every single Sunday morning at like
usually like 8 15 which is unfortunate
because it's the morning after Saturday
it's the morning after Saturday which
you know this has been the last what two
and a half years something like that so
I've never been able both of us though
both of us uh well we work together on
it yeah so like we're up like talking
title thumbnail and everything so it's
just it's like I've never slept in on a
Sunday which I know sounds like I sure
I'm complaining about nothing I think
Wilson's sleeping on Sundays the
Christians that's true yeah all right
well maybe I should yeah
[Music]
a.m every Sunday morning going back and
forth on title thumbnail we could do
this the night before but there's
something about like the morning of
where it's like that was a dynamic mode
yeah yeah but you have to come up with
something good the day before there's
not that sort of urgency to like make it
perfect right but when it's like 15
minutes before and we're going back and
forth over text over like what it does
feel kind of nice it does yeah and then
you get it and then you just anxiously
watch to see like how it performs and
then we Tinker this one will bomb for
sure this one's gonna blow up no yeah
morning I think for videos they either
do best in the bright early morning
before people are checking their phones
at breakfast or have to work you know
like six to seven and there's times
where if I need a video to go up it's
like yeah it's the same thing I wake up
at seven I click post on Facebook and
YouTube what because you know if it's
like getting out there because sometimes
I forget which one you can't uh you
can't schedule an Instagram or Tick Tock
yet but I'll get it out on there go back
to sleep because I would rather the
people on the East Coast see it versus
it's like okay I get up at 10.
people on the East Coast are like dude
it's too I don't need math it's 1am
they're like you know they're on their
lunch break they're in a meeting they're
seeing the video but they're not
watching there's no subtitles that's
like a whole you know I always think
about like
when are people listening and watching
with sound on early morning
end of the day yeah middle of the day
people are at work so you have to lunch
yeah but even at lunch it's loud and
they don't have headphones if they don't
you know so it's like is it subtitled
it's a not subtitle I was thinking about
like
like yeah just just watch people's
behavior as they scroll they're on a
subway they get headphones sure if they
do might be loud is it subtitled you
know and somebody's just eating at a
sweet green by themselves they don't
want to play it out loud because it's
insane so they're just kind of scrolling
just right so you're like how do I when
do I want to post what's best for people
around the world sure you go early
morning late at night it's interesting
you post and then go back to bed of
course
what's your schedule like
if you have a normal like a work
schedule that you have to like yeah
yeah Monday we record the podcast
Tuesday I'm usually writing or doing
like pre-production stuff for whatever
we're filming that week either film
Wednesday or Thursday I mean there's
just like miscellaneous stuff but like
every week I try to put out a video and
a podcast
like bare minimum yeah so everything
that gets plugged in around that is
either like meetings or collabs or phone
with other people tour is tough because
there's a lot of traveling so you're
weak it's like really Monday Tuesday and
you like fly out Wednesday or something
or it varies by a day or so but
really just that you know do you ever
get the feeling that you could be doing
more of course I I mean yeah it's like
you know you watch one interview with Mr
Beast and you're like what do I even try
yeah you know and and I think I think
it's Rogan episode if if you're a
YouTube guy listen to it it just [ __ ]
dude he's got I thought I had good
Insight on videos this dude this guy is
getting people from different countries
to
voice over what he's saying but he's
getting like popular actors in that
country he's got different channels for
different countries he's just like
Global yeah and I think he says in there
it's like 10 of the world speak English
I don't know what that is don't quote me
you should never quote me I don't know
much I learned from Snapple Lids but
he's like ten percent can't speak
English so let's dude that is
in terms of the world sorry I feel like
you were living yourself to so little
stuff and then I just like I the second
I watch an interview I hired another
editor and I was like I was like talking
I was like do I need a producer how do I
do I need a writer am I good enough and
it just made me want to expand so every
time you know I see something like that
or Eric he's great too he's [ __ ]
blown up right now but he's doing the
precautions and you meet him he's got a
big team he's hustling he's doing
everything uh he found the formula so I
see guys like that and I go I need to
one-up it but but it's a different side
of YouTube I think sketch comedy versus
what they do is like they're just meant
for the mass yeah it's just like it's
very clickable it's just
you know yeah do you think some of your
videos would translate well into other
languages I'd imagine it's maybe only a
sliver that another you know language
could understand or another country
could relate to what is interesting
because like for example when the white
Club video came out I did a show in
Canada they didn't have white claw there
yeah really people like we've heard
about this thing what is in the States
but then once they got it I started
getting messages like like a small bump
of views went up and people were like
dude we finally got them now I relate so
that's a good question I think something
Global like airpods maybe yeah you know
that would translate but
um
yeah I don't know
I I think I just make what I know best
and I I think whenever I try to go too
big or too like out of my element I feel
it instead of yours and so there's a
video you know it doesn't feel authentic
to me so
you could always do American stereotypes
in other countries of course yeah and
and I think you know and America is also
a massive place too so I'm very fine if
somebody in Brazil's like I don't
understand this [ __ ] I'm like well I
guess somebody in Connecticut does you
know I'm not trying to like obviously
Global the better
um especially with like reels and shorts
because they push that all over yeah
um so I do try to keep it somewhat
relatable and all that but you know I'm
doing as best as I can yeah I'm doing
what I know yeah you know I did a video
a while ago I was like uh when people
from La visit New York and I'm like
that's great because it encapsulates but
you know east and west coast and
everything in between if you're
yeah so like that to me I was like cool
I'm
I'm getting both sides of the country
yeah and what about for stand up what's
your process like for like writing jokes
and yeah test how do you test them out
to make sure they're funny so I write
everything in like a Notes app or the
voice memo and I was like talk it out I
think I mean I've been doing stand-up
for like nine years now like at this
point I at least know
an idea could be funny it's just finding
how to get it out you know it's like the
idea might be funny but the execution's
not or it's like the idea is whatever
but the exit you know like flip vice
versa type thing so I I think I just
like I usually put new stuff in the
middle of my set if I'm doing like 15
minutes at the Laugh Factory
around seven or eight I throw out a
quick premise if it bites keep going if
not then I'll be like okay do I want to
battle this or but sometimes it's like
what I what I think is funny isn't funny
and what I don't think is funny is funny
like I'll say the premise and it doesn't
really get anything and then I say the
next line and then that pops and you're
like oh I was wrong I was betting on
myself here but the audience was betting
on this
so there's no way to know unless you
really try it yeah so I always just
throw up new bits and I I think I just
as long as it's in my voice and I'm
passionate about it
people listen yeah you know it's
interesting you're kind of coming up
with a lot of stuff just off the Dome
when you're on stage like you try to see
something see if it bites and then you
know if it does you can proceed which is
does that happening does it ever make
you like nervous whenever you're on
stage no because you get in your head no
I I think it's like
it's it's like
I just like it feels like the same thing
you would and I'm not comparing
stand-up comedy to the NFL but like you
wouldn't like it's like asking an NFL
player be like do you think about the 70
000 people in the stadium watching you
you're like no they're just locked in
huh like there'll be moments where I'm
performing and I look up and I'm like
damn there's like 2 000 people watching
me right now and then I get right back
in it because I can't I'm just like in
like this like mode where I'm just on
and it's just like ever like nothing
matters you know I'm not worried about
taxes I'm not what I pay mine I'm not
worried about anything else but
performing in that hour so I does that
make sense yeah so I'm not like there's
no like outside thoughts and I'm just
like it's really it just feels like I'm
just like
did you ever get staged right of course
of course and you're on your way to get
rid of stage fright is just by by
following reps just doing it you know of
course dude a stage presence is
so much of all right somebody told me
this who should I remember who it's like
if you don't believe in your own jokes
why would the crowd you know like if
you're up there being nervous the
crowd's gonna be nervous unless your
energy and your jokes give off that like
kind of like nervous Shy Guy like Mitch
Hedberg or something like that would
make sense
but if I'm up there and I'm like hiding
behind the mic stand
fumbling over words there's no
confidence but if you walk out then you
like own it it's gonna help a lot people
are gonna be like this guy at least
knows what he's doing yeah he's bombing
comfortably is what's happening you know
but he knows it so but it just takes
reps it just takes time to figure out
your
and again I don't think of some stand-up
Guru but I I do think it's just just
repetition that's like a message I
always look for answers in life and I
think when I was coming up and stand up
I would like email big comedians I'd DM
them be like dude what are the answers
how do I do this what is the secret
there isn't really one it's just and I'm
sure you guys have found this in really
whatever whether it's podcasting or just
really anything it's
doing it yeah getting out there in the
Reps you've bombed before I'm guessing
on stage what's that like I've always
wondered I could imagine that it's
getting hot you get sweaty time slows
down I mean it feels like an edible is
just hitting just on repeat it's
terrible it's dude I have bombed
in front of my own crowd too I
and you just said how do you recover
from me yeah cause I feel like when it's
a downward spiral where it's like oh
[ __ ] I just bombed you there's no I feel
all like anxious I would bomb again well
I mean it's kind of like there's two
routes you take and I did this very much
so in the early route of my stand-up
days I'd be like I'd blame it on the
crowd which is not right to do I think
oh what that's oh
but Chad laugh at that yeah and that
will get like pity laughs but honestly
the thing is only you know how the joke
goes so if you just go to the next joke
after the crowd won't know and you ask
somebody after a crowd hey how was the
show loved it what's your favorite joke
there's like a you said something about
like pop schools or something that was
like what people remember out of an hour
versus what the performer remembers is
so different yeah we'll always beat
ourselves up I'll be like show is great
but this one fell flat so now if
something doesn't hit I just keep going
and but now I'm curious could that be
the audience or could that just be the
joke like could you retell a joke to a
different audience and they love it
because there's a Vibe of the audience
too right yeah and there's like
literally there's like um
I I think there's almost like a
beginner's luck with a brand new joke
like you'll like tell a random joke at
somewhere like you'll do it on the road
on like Des Moines Iowa and it murders
and you're like
we got a heater then you go back to LA
and you do it and it doesn't hit and
you're like
is it the crowd is it a bad joke did it
only work in Idaho like I have this joke
that I do about Amish people that I
because I just saw some in Indianapolis
and I was like mind blown and dude it
murdered in the midwest because they
have Amish but you do it in LA people
are like
do we have those again how much people
which ones honey do we have those here
so it's really just about trial and
error sure
I don't know why jokes get knocked out
of my set or jokes get put into my set
but every once in a while that's what I
was saying earlier I was like he was
huge rapid huge repertoire of jokes and
then sure enough I'll probably stop
doing that joke at some point and if
somebody somewhere is going to yell
something that correlates to the Amish
then I go boom got a Zinger for you if
I'm just starting a show and I like walk
out on stage and somebody's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it's so startling I think if
I'm in the middle of my show and I'm
like like I'm moving I'm grooving I'm in
the energy and I'm feeling it I'm locked
in and somebody else something I'll
[ __ ] fire back yeah some of them
missed some of them hit and when it hits
it goes crazy but like because the crowd
is watching you everybody can script
their stand up and then you do it but
that's all off the Dome that's all raw
in the moment that's why those moments
get the biggest pops and the clips that
I post on Tick Tock of crowd work
moments are like those sometimes go
crazy because people are like damn
that's like the funniest thing I had was
recently in San Francisco
on our podcast we talked about how to
blind people watch porn because it's an
educational podcast and
somebody I'm finishing up the San
Francisco show
maybe like five minutes left taking a
sip of water and this girl goes blind
people do watch porn you know crowd gets
tense and I realize that the lady who
yelled that was visually impaired and I
okay how do we address this and then I
just go back and forth and I I just
think if she yelled at the very
beginning of the show to be like what
where do I even go from here yeah but I
think I was just like warmed up and that
happened and it just like this it just
you couldn't expect that and it's just
like I had so much fun with it like what
did you what did you say uh well she
said something and I said oh no I'm over
here and that
that got a big ball but I was very
respectful yeah before I did
say that I don't know like I would be
too concerned about like offending her
like putting the wrong thing and so
and I think I I always do it without
malicious intent like I'm not like doing
it like like rude or like and I preface
the clip I say like hey I I am dumb I do
not know what's going on are you
visually impaired and then she said
something so I I'm putting myself out
there being like I don't know I'm dumb
are you and and then she said the thing
and that's why I said I'm over here and
that just
here yeah and now everybody
in that lap is nice because everybody's
like oh we're having fun here you know
if the crowd is laughing she's laughing
uh and I talked to her after the show
and she was like a sweetheart she like
loved it but I'd be so tense in that
moment because I feel like if you said
the wrong thing like that's that's
caught everything yeah yeah I mean
I think you know
and it's not like I and again I'm not
like attacking yeah sure she yelled out
at me yeah it's kind of like a
volleyball it's like a lot of balls in
your court and I I say in the clip I'm
like I feel like this is the Lord
testing me right now you know like do
you want to have another show tomorrow
night
um so I kind of like preface it preface
it and then and then what happens it the
clip is crazy I mean it's afterwards a
guy goes she's explaining how vision
impaired people watch porn and then this
guy in the balcony goes too long like
saying her explanation was too long and
then I start getting on that guy I'm
like she's blind not deaf you idiot like
she can hear you and at this point it's
just utter chaos and
it's just like I after I got off stage I
was like that was insane right and then
I was like yeah that look at that you
can't like that moment you can't
recreate yeah you gotta start putting
blind people in the audience so then
they can Heckle like that that's rude is
it rude
no we're gonna clip just that yeah
please please yeah do that
no no could you plant hecklers and then
like do people do that I'm sure people
do yeah but like dude you couldn't
there's no way you'd feel good about
yourself after that right right yeah
yeah and yeah that's that's not a good
crutch because then what if that person
gets covered that day and your big
clothes are you're like anybody on a
crutch here and then they're not there
you're like I said anybody you're
looking at a tour manager like where's
Ruben yeah oh God you in the back you're
on crutches right you could make it up
yeah I mean sure I mean sure bad idea
sure I mean comedians lie all the time
this happened this week that happened
four years ago like well today I was no
how often do you think that stuff's
actually true
I'm like does that actually happen I
think something close like something
like
like a guy will have a wild story and
it's like like a kernel of it is true
like the beginning thought somebody
sparked that thought and then they
accentuated
um or some of it is some guys are like
Joey Diaz I believe everything that man
says you know I don't know yeah he's
just like a jersey mafia guy and like
you hear him and you're like I believe
it and you can usually tell by the logic
and people talking about it you're like
sure it seems like it has a little logic
flow on it but
it's all accentuated I got one final
question I wanna I've always wanted to
ask a state about blind people Jack it
does it does not have to do with blind
people good it's uh because I love them
I've always wondered because I've been
to quite a few stand-up shows with a few
comedians that I like I adore right who
are these going against should I say
I'll say yeah sure I went to a Chris
Delia show and I went to uh at theovan
show loves you yeah and um I'm at these
shows and they're funny right like
they're they I laugh and everything but
when I listen to their podcasts it's
just like a whole different type of
laugh I think pressure there's no crowd
there's no audience you think that's
what it is I've always thought that
comedians in podcasts are like a hundred
times funnier than they are on stage I
love Theo he's one of my best friends
and just so
talented and he gets in his head a lot
because when he's at in the studio he's
just with himself right he's comfortable
he's in his own space and then there's 2
000 people you it's hard to be yourself
when you're performing you're a
performative aspect
so I think it's just that I think it's
also like the calculatedness of going up
on stage and the fact that every joke is
like pre-written so it's I mean to
imagine this podcast if there's two
thousand people here it'd be a totally
different podcast imagine recording any
YouTube video when there's 2 000 people
watching right you know you're if
somebody sneezes you're you're nothing
about that no if nobody laughs you tell
a joke or think about that if everybody
laughs now you think about that yeah
he's like you're not doing it for the
last you're just talking to talk you're
just talking from what you know best and
then you don't know those people you
know in their car or at work or at the
gym laughing to it you don't know like
like we post our podcast you guys place
your podcast nobody knows when they're
laughing sure you can read comments 3701
hilarious but then you're not performing
you're just talking and that's what
makes people connect with podcasters so
much is they're not putting on a
performance they're like this is just me
speaking from the heart no it makes
sense let's talk about your house really
quick
um what made you purchase the house
yeah I was done with renting I it's like
I've never loved the idea of just
throwing money at a landlord and like my
landlord's like
chill Venice bro and I'm like there's no
way my money's going to good use it's
going to Adderall and just long boards
just sector nines [ __ ] he's a great
dude but I just I don't know I I just
turned 30. everyone thinks I'm like 21
just turned 30 and I'm like dude I just
you know if this is the one big change I
make at 30 is start you know a mortgage
and having some
some assets yeah big word
I just you know that was it sure and I
was looking I was looking and the tour
just ended and I was like you know after
the tour I want to focus on that and I
saw one house the first house I looked
at is actually this one and then I
checked out like 15 or 20 more and this
one was like I would always relate it
back to that house I'm like this one's
sick but it doesn't have what blah blah
blah had got it and how long did it take
you from the time you saw the house to
make an offer it sounds like you stuck
20 homes it doesn't happen like a week
for like that week cool we love all the
[ __ ] out of them really oh yeah who were
they asking probably two something yeah
okay yeah and then we went in like 1.5 I
think I was like no
but did late I'm working with is like
the the real estate later mortgage who
is she give her a shout out Jessica
Jessica White I don't want to say her
last name boy She's Mine she'd love it
just she was real estate Jessica Felix
okay great yeah but she uh she's like
it's all like kind of dating she's like
you put an offer the seller immediately
says no ghost go away three weeks then
he's gonna be sitting there like why the
[ __ ] would they put that offer in they
did but they did put an offer you're
interested right should I is this should
I respond should I DM back should it be
seen
and kind of meet back and forth back and
forth back forth back and forth and then
it's like the new kind of three weeks go
by and you're like hey just wanna know
if you just have that offer here's new
offer with slightly more money but more
asks and it's just like this bag it's
all my name but you did that over the
holidays right like Thanksgiving through
Christmas that's a really slow time for
Real Estate so sellers basically to have
a home listed at the end of the year
like that usually means they have to
sell or they really really want to sell
yeah which I don't know if it's good or
bad
works for you worse for me no it works
it works for you yeah I love it just let
me do it guys I thought you're like yeah
they really gotta dump that property
it's gonna drop how's it going to drop
how's it going to drop everyone's saying
like 20 23. I think it's a risk uh the
luxury market in La so like above one
and a half has taken a huge hit so if
that's gonna drop pretty low no I could
see it I could realistically see like a
10 to 15 drop I think the luxury Mark
like 25 million and up I could totally
see like a 20 25 drop in the really
high-end Market uh but I think over one
and a half
I think probably a 10 to 15 drop is
probably the worst of it but the thing
is I think it's fine to buy right now
like it's not insane if you're planning
to keep it for the next 10 years I don't
think it makes a difference okay if you
were just gonna say well I'm gonna live
there for a few years and then sell it I
said no it's better to rent no no no no
and um but the issue is that it's the
interest rates is that right now your
the monthly payment is still higher than
it was at the peak so when Real Estate
was at its highest it was earlier really
a year ago but when you account for
interest rates the payment now is still
higher even though housing prices have
gone down
yeah and that's kind of like the
trade-off so yeah but you can buy now
how's that cheaper the interest is crazy
and then keep waiting and I just I don't
know I just I just don't want to stop
paying yeah for my lease and uh I don't
think it makes a difference if you're
like 10 years from now yeah chances are
gonna make money yeah I I mean I I'm a
pretty simple guy like if I find a place
that I like I like I'm not gonna be like
this is cool but like I need to be
closer to Nobu like I just don't care
like I just need a place where I can
work out of and that's what I loved
about this place it just had this
dedicated spot I was like this is a
great office it's called me and the
three people I work with like meet up
here we're writing we're editing it's
collaborative because all my friends
where I work now I'm in the west side of
town Los Angeles they're all in the
valley and it's like it's I'm done with
Wii transfers and and and Dropbox no
I need to air I need to be over the
shoulder and like trim that add this
dude like that there's something about
that in person that I do feel like is
incredible back and forth yeah that's
how it's like when me and John meet up
to edit like we'll just meet at our
podcast studio and it the ideas are just
bouncing back it's so much faster versus
me writing it out hoping he understands
my notes I'm like 301 make make her uh
uh come in sooner but this and then this
and then louder car Ferrari from room
he's like what is this but if I'm there
I'm like okay let's have a car command
it like it it just bounces on yeah it's
like it's so much better just to be
collaborative in same space yeah cool I
think I think that's a good time right
we're out of time we're good okay I
actually got one more question trying to
catch a title right here okay Trevor
what is the most that you've made in one
day
foreign
I made a few people smile and that's all
that matters to me I'm not a money guy
what's up yep meet the man who makes
people smile and it makes people smile
12 mil I honestly have no idea all right
I can't look at money every day I also
lose my head because I'll be like Oh My
Views are down My Views are up I heard
it you know
as long as I can pay for my rent
now your mortgage yeah
yeah
scary now the bar is so much higher I
don't know there's there's got to be
something in the top in the episode talk
about we got it yeah cool still make it
too quick baby oh oh well no we'll go we
can run it by you yeah cool cool let me
know thank you so much for coming on
Trevor yeah nice re-meeting you and uh
time yeah cool times the charm thank you
guys so much and until next time